by and large small businesses are
optimistic about the new year but they
are still concerned about specific
things in today's date on your side we
connect with one expert on the outlook
for the new year and suggestions on how
small business owners can reach a wider
consumer base
there are some 33 million small business
owners in the United States the small
business administration reports one
million new small businesses were formed
across the country last year but at the
same time eight hundred thousand small
businesses closed it's never been easier
to open a small business but it's also
never been harder to maintain a small
business Brett Sussman tracks small
business activity and the challenges
they face a recent survey reveals
business owners think 2023 will be a
good year from a revenue perspective but
many are concerned about the cost side
and expect supply chain issues to
continue until the summer they're
actually diversifying the number of
suppliers they use to make sure they
have products on their shelves but that
can mean that they miss out on both
discounts of going with one supplier
two-thirds of small businesses say
they'll be spending more on a marketing
budget this year Sussman says Marketing
Online is even more important than ever
this year as a lot of purchases are
happening on social media one of the
biggest things that we see from consumer
is they're splitting their wallet
between in-store and online and small
business owners need to be prepared for
that and they need to be prepared for an
omni-channel perspective and if you're
looking to Target a newer demographic it
may be gen Z or it may be Millennials
you have to try some different platforms
such as
hiring and retaining workers crucial for
small businesses many still having to
offer signing bonuses to attract a good
talent pool